[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur tv5 monde et vos chaînes
locales et régionales de la tnt tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité
elle se déguste sans modération les
glaces sont appréciés quand les
températures grimpent et le nombre de
glaciers ne cesse d'augmenter à bordeaux
nous expliquera tv7 la chaîne du groupe
sud ouest dans un instant dans second
cité des territoires nous ouvrons une
rubrique cet été les livres de l'été
c'est l'une des activités favorites des
français pendant la période estivale et
dont nous vous proposons de découvrir
quelques auteurs et leurs ouvrages
avant de faire nos valises nous serons
notamment aujourd'hui en duplex avec
antoine sénanque pour son livre le
cerveau m'a beaucoup déçu l'esprit non
dans un instant dans ce journal
et puis en fin de journal nous irons
dans les airs avec la découverte de
l'activité de parapente sensations et
images époustouflantes garantie avec la
rédaction de 8 mont blanc sur place je
vous le disais dans les titres c'est une
tendance estivale qui ne se dément plus
les glaciers sont de plus en plus
nombreux dans nos villes et villages en
france et après tout quoi de mieux qu'un
peu de soleil d'été pour déguster une
bonne glace à bordeaux vous allez le
voir les adresses gourmandes se
multiplient et les professionnels
regorge d'idées pour se démarquer de la
concurrence
clémentine rivière et manon gazin pour
tv7 la chaîne du groupe sud ouest à
bordeaux regarder leur nombre se
multiplient d'années en années les
glaciers investissent les rues
commerçantes de bordeaux c'est notamment
le cas de ce glacier charentais qui
vient d'ouvrir une boutique place du
parlement
c'est des glaces artisanales donc sans
colorant sans ajout d'arômes sans
conservateur sans huile de palme sans
gluten et on est même sur les sort dès
qu'ils sont vegan et avec des matières
premières d'exception qui sont triés sur
le volet on sait qu'une très forte
concurrence la juste sur le petit
secteur parlement on est on est
cette figure assez hachée sept autres
glaciers on a misé sur le 100 % bio ou
90 parfums sont proposés on a des
parfums vraiment atypique
par exemple là on a une nouveauté cette
année on a de la bière on a on a eu du
roquefort du foie gras des choses qu'on
trouvera nulle part ailleurs quoi il
peut écrire sur une devanture artisanale
sur le mans il ya un employé qui a fait
avec tous ses écrits mais celle les
vrais mots et je pense que les gens le
sentent et c'est pour ça qu'ils
reviennent des concepts novateurs voient
aussi le jour
lancée l'an dernier ce glacier ambulant
a misé sur un véhicule 100% électrique
et a choisi de quitter le centre-ville
pour se positionner sur les quais dans
une démarche de circuits courts et de
diversification de ses produits
alors l'été ça va s'appeler amine
clients un parent après midi ont fait
pas que des glaces en fait donc l'
avantage de faire des glaces des cafés
des beignets des crêpes des jus ça
permet de travailler toute l'année
maintenant des glaciers qui pourraient
être pris d'assaut avec l'arrivée des
beaux jours et des températures
estivales
les confinements successives nous
ont-ils poussé à consommer davantage
locale pendant toute cette crise si la
réponse paraît évidente c'est oui le
temps passant la réalité s'est avéré
différentes
certains ont repris leurs habitudes
d'avant locaux vides 19
d'autres se sont engagés dans une
consommation plus éco responsable la
preuve dans la loire avec ce reportage
de la rédaction de tl7 la télévision de
la loire une fois confiner les ligériens
se sont mis à plus cuisiner que
d'habitude mais ont-ils gardé leurs
habitudes de consommation où se sont-ils
tourner vers des produits plus locaux
n'ont pas du tout du fait que bas comme
j'ai dit je travaillais donc c'était
tout en urgence donc les grandes
surfaces et le boulot donc aucun
changement à ce niveau là j'ai fait un
peu de marche à pied
j'ai vu un petit primeur je rentrais pu
rester comme ça et j'y retourne pour le
moment après l annonce de la fermeture
des marchés les maraîchers et les
producteurs de la loire ont dû trouver
des alternatives pour continuer à vendre
leurs produits on retrouve aujourd'hui
un maraîcher à saint-just-saint-rambert
sylvain soulas
il a créé un drive grâce à facebook
alors le drian en fait voilà ici on a un
camion avec nos collines marchandises
qui ont été commandés on l'aimé touche
des dents les gens arrivent entre 15h et
18h quand ils veulent ils ont même pas
besoin de descendre en voiture des
paniers avec des légumes de saison c'est
ce que sylvain propose entre 70 et 80
panier était commandée par semaine en
mars et avril
aujourd'hui il y a toujours de la
demande et 50 paniers continue d'être
vendu
mais je te complètement une clientèle
noël encore nus quelques clients
saint-etienne bucs ont leurs banques qui
sont venus nous a jusqu'à ici mais c'est
à 95% clientèle complètement nouvelle
quoi une clientèle nouvelle c'est aussi
ce qu'a constaté le magasin vrac en
verre à saint-etienne on a eu des
une des gens du quartier qui sont venus
découvrir un petit peu l'épicerie après
on n'a pas vraiment de recul sur le fait
que sur la fidélité du coût de ces gens
là derrière mais en tout cas en tout cas
on a vu des nouvelles têtes
la boutique est toujours restée ouverte
et le chiffre d'affaires s'est plutôt
bien équilibré une période moins
difficile que prévu pour les quatre
salariés nous il y avait des gens qui
venaient spécialement ici pour trouver
de la farine parce que y en avait pas
dans les supérettes dans les chaînes
classiques
ce qui est certain c'est que cette
période aura été synonyme d' initiatives
positives pour ses partisans de
l'agriculture locale
et dans le reste de l'actualité en
martinique une herbe marine colonisent
les herbiers locaux depuis 2006 les
effets de cette nuisibles sur
l'écosystème marin du littoral préoccupe
les chercheurs du cnrs notamment pour le
développement des tortues les précisions
de tom ganio de via à tv martinique sur
place elle s'appelle halophiles à
stipule acea
cette aire marine originaire de l'océan
indien colonisent les herbes et de
martinique et bouleverse l'écosystème du
littoral première impactés par ce
dérèglement les tortues marines les
conséquences sur le long terme
inquiètent cette équipe de chercheurs du
cnrs premier problème c'est que ces
termes marine est beaucoup moins
intéressante sur le plan énergétique et
donc beaucoup moins nutritives or on a
des tortues vertes qui sont en phase de
croissance ici qu'ils vont rester une
quinzaine d'années et qui repartiront
une fois qu'elles ont atteint la
maturité sexuelle
donc là actuellement ça peut poser des
problèmes de carences même aussi
l'arrivée de certaines maladies
deuxième chose il se trouve que c'est
les feuilles de nanofils as tu places y
sont des très petites feuilles
donc ça forme un tapis au niveau des
herbiers donc beaucoup moins intéressant
et qui sert qui ne joue pas son rôle de
leur série pour mesurer le réel impact
de cette herbe sur les tortues il faut
étudier leur comportement
direction la plage dans ce noir dans ces
eaux limpides on recense pas moins de
300 tortues quelques unes vont être
équipés d'une balise qui permettra aux
chercheurs de récolter des données
ce sont des apnéistes professionnels qui
sont envoyées pour les attraper il dit
au préalable
tout un travail de repérage
on refaire toujours les tortues depuis
la surface en un ventre qu'il ment et
elles sont soit rentrés sains âgés sont
en train de manger
après l'ondé comportement différent
suivant leur nage soissons rapide soit
sont lentes
une fois attrapé les tortues sont
identifiés à l'aide d'un scanner
elles sont mesurées et pesées afin de
contrôler leur croissance l'opération de
la poste de la balise peut alors
commencer
son utilisation est primordial dans
l'analyse comportementale des tortues on
récupérera les données qui sont
justement dans le dans l'appareil qui
nous permettront d'avoir toute
l'activité notamment le temps passé en
alimentation repos les interactions le
temps passé à se déplacer la qualité des
herbiers qu'offrent les eaux de
martinique est essentielle à la
croissance des tortues la préservation
de cet écosystème est donc primordial
pour la pérennité de cette espèce
une mission à laquelle s'attelle sans
relâche des scientifiques
restons à l'eau dans ce grand jt des
territoires en corse ou la plongée sous
marine permet de découvrir les richesses
de l'île de beauté la biodiversité
marine bien sûr mais aussi plus
étonnamment l'épave d'un avion militaire
présent aux abords de calvi celui ci se
situe à 28 mètres de profondeur il
s'agit d'un bombardier américains
échouer le 14 février 1944
aujourd'hui l'épave représente à elle
seule l'inde et spot incontournable de
corse
propos recueillis par via télé pas aisée
franck rollin gérant du club de plongée
c'est un bombardier donc une forteresse
volante qui a donc à mairie c'était en
février 1944
suite à un accrochage que cet avion a eu
au dessus de l'italie et la corse étant
le premier département français libéré
en octobre 43 il est donc venu pour se
poser à calvi malheureusement ayant des
problèmes de moteur il était obligé dame
est rien il est unique en son genre le
fait du peuple de profondeur de l'épave
en fait c'est une des seules et pas en
avions donc en gros porteurs comme celui
ci qui est dans moins de 30 mètres de
haut pour y accéder c'est minimum de 40
dont gérant cadres et 40 mètres et les
niveaux supérieurs
que diriez vous maintenant de prendre un
café et de faire réparer votre vélo dans
un même lieu et bien l'idée a de quoi
séduire surtout en cette période
estivale où il fait bon de pédaler et
c'est le concept choisi à rennes par une
crêperie qui vous permet d'entretenir
vos deux roues vous allez voir l'idée
vient d'angleterre et a pour objectif de
donner une autre image du vélo en ville
écoutez à ce propos le gérant de citron
le nom de ce café vélo situé à rennes au
micro de la chaîne locale de la tnt thé
vert c'est tous les vélos convent qu'on
a trouvé sur le bon coin qu'on nous a
données
on les retape sont garantis chez citron
un an et on les vend à des prix
abordables pour ça puisse plaire au
maximum de gens grâce à six trous
beaucoup de gens et puis pousser la
porte d'un réparateur de vélos pour la
première fois ce que je pense que ça
décomplexe les gens le fait que je sois
un café aussi et on a eu beaucoup de
personnes âgées
où de jeunes étudiants qui n'osaient pas
retapé leur petit vélo tout un bel et
bien grâce aux citrons je le sais ça a
été fait pour beaucoup beaucoup de vélo
et ses deux victoires en deux et en plus
de faire du vélo cet été vous profiterez
sûrement de vos vacances pour lire un ou
plusieurs ouvrages
c'est l'une des activités favorites des
français pendant la période estivale la
lecture et le grand jt des territoires
vous propose de découvrir quelques
auteurs et leurs ouvrages pendant ces
vacances avant de faire vos valises
nous sommes aujourd'hui en duplex avec
antoine sénanque bonjour antoine
sénanque bonjour neurologue dans la vie
vous êtes l'auteur de plusieurs ouvrages
dont 1 paru récemment le cerveau m'a
beaucoup déçu l'esprit non aux éditions
guy trédaniel
ce livre résume t-il bien l'idée
générale de votre essai oui le titre
résume bien l'idée générale de laisser
en réalité les neurosciences ont
surestimé le cerveau à moi je suis
neurologue
je ne vois pas le cerveau dans le cadre
d'un laboratoire ou d'un centre
d'imagerie je le vois dans la vie au
contact des malades et en 2021
il faut reconnaître une chose c'est
qu'on ne guérit aucune grande maladie
neurologique dégénérative
on accompagne les patients qui ont une
maladie d'alzheimer on traite les
symptômes des patients qui ont discours
aux en plaques unique parkinson mais on
ne guérit pas à ces maladies antoine
sénanque vous le disiez vous êtes
neurologue de métier cet essai est il
une critique quelque part de votre
vision du cerveau et des capacités qu'on
souhaite lui conférer oui c'est une
critique de la vision notre cerveau est
vu comme un organe qui sait tout et qui
peut tout le livre est aussi une
réflexion sur les relations entre
l'esprit et cerveau entre la conscience
et le cerveau depuis le 17e siècle la
science considère que
l'esprit est une création du cerveau et
même une sécrétion du cerveau comme
l'habit est une sécrétion du choix or à
l'évidence le domaine spirituel dépasse
de loin
l'espace du cerveau d'après-vous médecin
patient et citoyens nous devrions tous
davantage nos veillées en fait à autre
chose que la raison et le cerveau je
crois qu'il faut pas se méfier du
cerveau ou bien qu'ils nous égare
souvent mais il faut pas considérer que
le cerveau est ce qui nous définit ce
qui nous définit c'est l'esprit c'est la
spiritualité
il dépasse le cerveau en histoire parce
que l'esprit est apparu avant les
premiers systèmes nerveux dans
l'histoire de l'évolution
et puis en géographie parce que les
neurosciences ont toujours été incapable
de localiser la conscience de localiser
les esprits au sein du cerveau l'esprit
de guérison dont vous parlez qu'est ce
que c'est concrètement toits de ces
langues alors l'esprit de guérison ça
c'est quelque chose qui reste assez
mystérieux et très discutée et
auxquelles je crois
premier facteur qui a été déterminé
c'est le fait de croire en sa guérison
même si les médecins vous dites qu'il
n'ya plus d'espoir plus d'espérance
croire en ses guérisons deuxième facteur
étudié et reconnu par plusieurs études
c'est accepter l'aide des autres le
troisième facteur est un peu plus
complexe c'est changer quelques choses à
sa manière de voir et à sa manière de
vivre
on y croit on n'y croit pas moi je crois
en l'esprit de guérison et je pense que
tout le monde a vraiment intérêt à y
croire voilà merci antoine sénanque pour
vos réponses je rappelle que vous êtes
l'auteur de cet essai le cerveau m'a
beaucoup déçu l'esprit pneus paru aux
éditions guy trédaniel et que l'on peut
acheter bien sûr sur internet ou en
librairie
tout cet été il est caché au plus
profond de la forêt de roue au bois dans
les vosges et élevage mais la capra de
floriane de lucas compte aujourd'hui une
trentaine de chèvres miniature une
passion devenue profession pour la
spinalienne d'origine qui a vu la
popularité de ces animaux explosé ces
dernières années au même titre que la
demande un sujet d'arsène gay et de
l'eaa turquie et pour vos jeux
télévision c'est adorable petite chèvre
[Musique]
ici tout est miniature véritable paradis
au coeur de la forêt de rang au bois
l'élevage bella capra accueille
aujourd'hui une petite trentaine de mini
et micro chèvres sur ce terrain de 2
hectares passionné depuis toujours par
ses animaux floriane deluca se lance
dans l'élevage en 2012 la spinalienne
d'origine passe alors rapidement de deux
à dix chèvres avant de devenir
professionnel il ya cinq ans est de
tripler son cheptel
une vocation qui nécessite beaucoup
d'attention faut savoir que non les
élèves dans le sens où ces animaux de
compagnie donc un minimum de présence
une fois deux fois par jour pour les
particuliers pour de la compagnie ça
suffit moi par contre vu que je fais de
l'élevage et des bébés
il faut être là régulièrement tous que
ça va être à 4 5 fois par jour alors
qu'elle a vendu toutes ses bêtes
l'éleveuse reçoit encore des dizaines de
demandes pour ces petits caprins
attachant dont le prix varie entre 220
et 480 euros et les ventes ne cessent
d'augmenter année après année petite
taille mais forte personnalité et
tondeuses écologiques les avantages sont
aussi nombreux que les raisons d'être
méfiants j'ai des clients qui mettent
des caméras après moi j'ai mes chiens de
protection
donc c'est vrai que là ça évite que les
gens rendent le terrain sans y être
invité c'est pareil par rapport aux
renards aux rapaces tout ça moi j'ai
aucun souci à ce niveau là j'ai un chien
qui protège h 24 mai chiffres et le
danger peut également venir du cheptel
lui même c'est le cas pour ce bébé
biberon comme l'éleveuse aime à les
appeler rejeté par sa mère à la
naissance c'est elle qui s'occupe de lui
pendant ces trois mois de sevrage avant
qu'il ne rejoigne le reste de l'élevage
où on est sûr de la chèvre miniature
parce que la race n'est pas reconnu en
tant que tel en france et dans la chaîne
miniature on a plusieurs tailles
donc on a de la naine de l'extranet de
la taille et d'extra toys extrapole plus
petit et donc là on est sur un gabarit
donc un petit bébé extra toy
il ya d'autres animaux qui pouvait
arriver oui notamment à cochons
miniatures qu'on attend dans un mois un
nouvel animal de compagnie qui viendra
rejoindre les chèvres et spitz déjà
présents au sein de l'élevage installé à
rend au bois depuis huit mois seulement
floriane deluca songe donc déjà à la
suite et aimerait prochainement doubler
le nombre de ses petites protégées et
actions les côtes d'armor à présent dans
cette édition pour découvrir un site
dont la rénovation touche à sa fin celui
du château du guildo en bretagne près de
dinard ille vacances à rouvrir au public
après six mois de travaux une
application permettra désormais aux
visiteurs de se projeter dans l'histoire
du lieu moderniser et sécuriser
c'est une belle idée de balade que nous
raconte laura rochette pour les chaînes
tv aux et tb sud
les chefs de groupe le télégramme en
bretagne on va relever sa un certain
niveau pour bien analyser ses différents
espaces sécurisés consolidé mise en
valeur le château du guildo a créé un
pourra à nouveau accueillir du public
un vaste programme de travaux a été
initiée il ya maintenant six ans par le
conseil départemental coup
d'accélérateur et d'être vraiment de
2016 avec cette volonté d'en faire un
un point touristique fort de la côte
nord et de l'intégrer pleinement
parmi les sites culturels départementaux
l'objectif premier était bien de
sécuriser et de renforcer le site
le second de proposer un meilleur
accueil des publics différents
aménagements étaient prévues pour les
personnes en situation de handicap une
application a aussi été pensé pour
améliorer l'expérience des visiteurs en
3d ça va nous permettre de équipés de
smartphone une tablette de visiter le
château et de projeter la réalité du
château au 14e siècle ou au 16e siècle
est de pouvoir switcher très rapidement
d'une réalité à l'autre le département
investit près de 3 millions d'euros pour
la réalisation des différents travaux
c'est vrai qu'on peut se dire à ce sont
des ruines les ja lire ni à
l'information qu'elles délivrent
il ya le côté aussi romantique parce que
l'on se trouve dans un cap qui est tout
à fait magique donc espace naturel
sensible classé natura 2000 on allait
faut qu'ils sont juste un peu plus loin
donc c'est un lieu de promenade ce
château est à la fois un lieu d'histoire
mais aussi un lieu de rêverie les
amoureux du site peuvent toujours
profiter des sentiers de randonnée qui
borde le château de la faune et de la
flore et de la magie des lieux
une autre idée de sortie à présent dans
ce grand vite et des territoires à
montauban cette fois ci où le musée de
linge mais talonneur ferdinand philippe
d'orléans leduc était un passionné d'art
près de 200 oeuvres sont ainsi avoir
lors de cette exposition au partenariat
avec le musée du louvre et ce jusqu'au
24 octobre premier tour de salle avec
maelys figuier pour vient occitanie
regarder ferdinand philippe d'orléans le
prince idéal est à l'honneur au musée
ingres de montauban
dès la première salle vous pourrez
découvrir cette exposition en
partenariat avec le célèbre musée du
louvre pour la première fois les deux
lieux culturels ont pu rassembler une
partie de sa collection près de 200
oeuvres sont proposés elle parcourt la
vie du prince de sa naissance à sa mort
le projet est né autour d'une oeuvre
exceptionnelle qui est le portrait par
ingres du duc d'orléans lors ce duc
d'orléans
c'est le fils aîné du roi louis-philippe
nous sommes au milieu du 19e siècle il
est mort dans un accident de voiture h
de cheval en 1842 et il est devenu une
espèce de à la fois d'icône de la mode
donc c'était un prince moderne qui
voulait changer des choses et le
portrait d'un grain a contribué
justement faire l'image d'un principal
l'idée d'échanger des collections
remonte à 2019 le musée du louvre et
celui de montauban en signant un
partenariat afin de présenter des
expositions commun l'exposition montre à
la fois des collections du musée de
montauban puisque le portrait du duc
d'orléans est un portrait d'ingres pour
lequel nous conservons des documents des
dessins préparatoires des tableaux qui
sont en rapport et donc c'est
intéressant de montrer à nos visiteurs
que nos collections font écho à celles
du plus grand musée du monde et peuvent
éclairer des chefs-d'oeuvre du plus
grand musée du monde
le duc d'orléans était passionné d'art
est très proche des artistes à sa mort
tout le pays et bouleversé son dynamisme
de l'art et de la création artistique
s'arrête il accepter de d'aller poser
dans leur atelier d'aller découvrir leur
travail à cette occasion de le commenter
il ne contestait pas les prix qui lui
demandait hiller mais c'est souvent tout
à fait le choix de leur sujet
donc un mécène comment on en rêverait
l'exposition a été inaugurée le 18 juin
dernier et vous pourrez l'admirer
jusqu'au 24 octobre 2021 à limoges à
présent le musée de la libération
propose lui aussi une exposition
originale celle des oeuvres de l'artiste
polonaise rivka messine guerre sur ces
400 oeuvres propriété du collectionneur
bernard michaud 71 ont été données au
musée
elle retrace notamment son parcours
marqué par l'exil le nazisme et le désir
aussi d'être mère explications d'alain
druot de la rédaction locale de 7 à
limoges sur place soixante et onze
oeuvres de l'artiste polonaise et ficam
et signèrent sont désormais sécurisées
au musée de la résistance de limoges
elles proviennent de la collection de
bernard michaud qui en a fait don au
musée etc par un sauvetage que commence
l'histoire de ce taux
400 oeuvres allait être perdu dans la
destruction de l'atelier parisien où
elle était stockée
cette collection raconte la vie de
l'artiste
rifca mais singer à l'âge de 15 ans est
parti de son village natal en pologne
devant naturellement devant la poursuite
et la tyrannie du nazisme
elle a exprimé dans toutes ces peintures
sont sam nostalgie si vous voulez de son
pays et de ses de ses coutumes et en
même temps de sa religion puisqu'elle
était israélite pour manger pour avoir
un petit peu de de subsides
elles faisaient des des petites
aquarelles lequel vendait comme ça à la
sauvette si on peut dire marqué par sa
communauté son oeuvre est dans la lignée
de celle de chagall dont on perçoit
l'influencé la représentation si vous
voulez de la période nazie si vous
voulez particulièrement et celle ci
c'est c'est l'exode
c'est l'exode quand vous regardez ce
tableau vous voyez les costumes le
monsieur barbu quête au milieu avec
cette casquette qui représente bien ce
que l'on trouve dans les oeuvres de
chagall d'ailleurs souvent
[Musique]
et on referme ce grand jt des
territoires avec des images
impressionnantes et une vue imprenable
sur la chaîne des aravis sans sa voix au
grand bornand le parapente est une
activité incontournable de l'été
ils sont des centaines chaque semaine à
faire leurs premiers baptêmes la tête
dans les nuages
victoria lopes journaliste pour la
chaîne montblanc s'est envolé elle aussi
elle nous propose ces images
impressionnantes
regardez le parapente est une des
activités phare du grand bornand l'été
l'école erling se situer au pied de la
télécabine du rosais fait découvrir les
joies du vol à près de 300 passagers par
semaine
particularité du site l'air de décollage
situé sur la pente sud ouest du mont
l'achat à châtillon n'est pas accessible
par la route pour accéder aux sous au
décollage donc au sommet du domaine
skiable
on enchaîne d'abord le télécabine du
rosais puis le télésiège du l'achat qui
nous avaient jusque là 2000 mètres en
gros il faut compter dix minutes de
télécabines suivi de dix points minutes
de télésiège ce qui nous amène en eau en
une vingtaine de minutes
nous arrivons sur l'air de décollage
finie la rigolade pour moi xavier me
fait décoller j'ai peur mais c'est vous
fout moi bon je courais c'est vous on y
vend ok je suis prêt à aller en
augmentant
avant
voilà
son avance on avance ne vole pas ça mon
appréhension xavier me rassure en
expliquant les rudiments du vol en
parapente
donc on va retrouver notre collègue
sylvain qui est au rock des ars et qui
comme tu le vois a pris déjà une
ascendance
donc il va nous lancer nous indiquer la
route
l'air est transparent donc tous les
indices ont leur importance notamment
les autres parapente ou les oiseaux bien
entendu avec 1000 mètres de dénivelé
entre le décollage et la zone
d'atterrissage
le vol dure au minimum 15 à 20 minutes
de quoi apprécier la vue sur la chaîne
des aravis le mont blanc quand il n'est
pas cachée derrière les nuages et même
le lac léman au loin après quelques
virages un peu plus acrobatiques pour
perdre en altitude
l'atterrissage se passe en douceur ou
presque
sur les jambes le retour à l'école se
fait en voiture les passagers du jour
sont aussi heureux que moi j'ai pas les
mots c'est un truc de ouf
tu ressens tous les sensations les
éléments et on voyait même pas les mots
c'est incroyable c'est voilà un premier
baptême super sympa le
le vol le démarrage a été instantané pas
de
de trouille rien du tout et bat le
panorama est splendide super quoi c'est
vraiment magnifique
je repars donc la tête dans les nuages
l'esprit aéré et avec la sensation
d'avoir touché du bout des doigts le
rêve d'icare
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivi
sur vos chaînes locales et régionales de
la tnt et sur tv5 monde
on se retrouve bien sûr pour une
prochaine édition avec un tour complet
de l'actualité estivale dans nos
territoires
alors à tous et bon courage
[Musique]